emerald hello from the morning show here
in los angeles and congratulations to
you
good for you uh you described it as so
tiny or so heavy
and so cold now that you're better
acquainted with oscar several hours
later
uh how would you describe it i mean it's
pretty amazing but it is very heavy
um but maybe i just need to go to the
gym or maybe i can use him as a
as a wait um no it's just
i don't know what i expected i think
i've only ever held a pretend one
so it's very exciting thank you our next
question is et
canada et canada next question okay it's
so wonderful to see you again and
congratulations on this big win two
things
first of all zack morris is trending now
on twitter because of you
and no oh god humber's saying really
no it is oh no and now that you have an
awesome
in your hand yep go ahead
no no no nothing i'm i'm listening i'm
just
complicated yeah and
because you have an oscar in your hand
and you are pregnant will that now
become one of the names that could
potentially call your child
well you know actually if jeff if if
zack morris
doesn't mind you know this situation
i think i think we should just really
give it a go
thank you our next question will be from
screen international screen
international
hi hi there emerald i'm calling in from
london uh
so huge congratulations must be tired
you're just
so tired
i'm enlivened by the uh great success
several british winners so yourself and
daniel anthony christopher
uh what do you think the future looks
like for the uk film industry
god i mean that's a big question i think
it's amazing every you know
what an amazing place uh what an amazing
place to come from and it's so
supportive of the arts and there are so
many incredibly talented people
and yeah i think it's just getting
better and
better i hope um and yeah
and it's just so exciting this year to
see so many as you say british people
succeed and
just in such a huge international forum
so
yeah i feel very proud and grateful
thank you our last question is coming
from
e last question from e hi emerald
congratulations
i am just so happy for you and proud of
you and
you described this film as a poison
popcorn film
can you explain what that means exactly
and will you continue to make these
poison popcorn movies
um i don't i don't know i i mean i think
i think i i always hope to make
something that
would yeah that would that people would
want to go and see
that even if it's about something
difficult and troubling that
yeah that that it would still be a movie
that you would go and watch with your
friends with your boyfriend and you
would talk about it afterwards and so
part of it was that
that it felt kind of glossy and feminine
and poppy
and that yeah that but it was discussing
some very
difficult and dark subject matter so i
think
probably that is something i will do in
the future a little bit
but yeah amazing